The joe rogan experience.
Okay.
Does the end of the show.
Uh,
thank you very much.
Bert.
Kreischer supposed to be here tomorrow.
I haven't talked to him.
Um,
you so hopefully we got it all.
I know he's traveling today.
Hopefully we got it all worked out.
But check Twitter and you'll know for sure.
I love you bitches.
I'll see you later.
This is your music.
Yeah.
What is,
don't make fun of.
It's really good.
Is it a song?
Yeah,
it's called VCR guys in the commercial.
Tammy,
you're live so bad.
Digest meat.
It's Sas.
Do you need to go to a doctor,
Ben?
It's bad.
Banks.
Who needs medical science?
Stock Ninja kick its ass.
Your rates are still stupid syrup.
It still sucks.
They just fails miserably.
Gout Ninja kick its ass.
You got a real problem,
dude.
Where's that one you had that one song you made with your ex
sex.
Brian's.
It's terrifying.
Humanity has ever produced you have a worm in your brain.
They tried nature's pick.
No ass.
Southbound celebrate job.
Well done.
Knowledge.
A beats honor.
It's t mobile kicked our ass come up much too.
So I can drive back to 1985 I don't need nothing fancy.
I won't go too far.
I just need,
I'm fine.
C
Yes.
Pro somewhere.
Someone making this.
They're going to make this the features on their myspace page.
I didn't answer called the um,
story rid of words that are fair.
A little right
called word salad on all circuits are busy now.
Right?
What does that song you made with your ex?
Can you make a song with your ex?
Yeah.
What's that one about?
It was kind of a good one.
What was it?
What was it about?
Well,
there's the one who I'm punching the dog.
Is that what the one you're talking about it now,
but it was good.
It was fun.
Uh Oh,
Juno Ish.
Yeah.
That's actually just a remake of a song.
Oh,
don't do that because you don't have rights.
But there was the other one.
The other one's punching the dog was about punching my door.
Do you think that's funny man?
Yeah.
Play that one.
John is good or should we not play it?
Maybe we should all night.
Good.
They're all my stupid songs right now.
I don't want to leave people disappointed.
Okay,
well not going to work.
I wish I could've heard it.
They're going to think it's better than it was.
They're going to leave now thinking that I missed out on something good.
Would reality folks,
is it shut off your iPhone?
Shut off.
Disconnect from you stream.
Please don't listen to what we're doing here right now.
Cause you to waste your time.
This is right.
You crack rock clicking on the link.
It's
okay.
Stop.
Terrible.
This is worse than the other one.
This is where pulled up,
man.
Please stop it along with your own song.
That's terrible,
bro.
Like it.
No.
Well,
I could play the January song.
Nope.
That's no copyright.
That's actually really good.
They were good.
That's really good.
That's it.
That's a wrap,
right?
Cause the end of the show.
Okay.
Hello.